is Croatia ready for Europe in the
interview Croatian president evil yessuh
povitch mr. president in just a few days
Croatia will join the European Union
mission accomplished more or less yes we
are going to be you member but we are
not going to finish our reforms EU is if
one itself Croatia will reform itself
and we benefit from this procedure
because now we are better society than
before but not perfect we'll be talking
about this later on more in-depth let's
first take a brief look at Syria and
latest developments there austria's with
drawing its 300 peacekeepers from the
goal on her hates Croatia took the same
decision for its 100 UN troops what
consequences will the collapse of the UN
peacekeeping mission have I don't think
so definitely circumstances have changed
because UN mission was established to
protect or to control border between
Syria and Israel and now there is war
there and new circumstances and it's out
of mission it's more and there it was
planned when a mission was established
so it was really necessary to withdraw
because the troops are not in enough
number and they are not ecliptic
properly for new circumstances but what
does it mean for the region especially
for Israel definitely it's a challenge
security challenge for not only por el
but for the other in the region mr.
president some 20 years ago your country
are through also went through a civil
war and eventually Croatia is not cereal
or sorry you it was aggression what's
gracious 20 years ago your country went
through a war and eventually croatia
gained independence from
luvya what was your personal role in
that conflict I was Professor living in
Zagreb so my role was very modest so I
wrote it at the referendum for our
independence but I was not involved in
this historical event in the early 90s
you quit politics for nearly a decade
and then you rejoined the social
democratic party why did you take that
break in your career the main reason was
that I didn't consider myself as a part
of political society if I can name it so
I was not involved in politics that I
wanted to be involved in law and arts
and of course I was not always satisfied
with Social Democrats role in the period
and that was made two main reasons for
it law and arts you studied two subjects
yet law and music yes you can see
yourself more as a politician or a
lawmaker or a musician what is more no I
had different stages in my life so I
lived two parallel lives I was law
professor and musician and then later I
became politician and now I'm just
politician because this job I now
occupying is from early in the morning
till early in the morning so you don't
compose music anymore do you miss it yes
of course but men date is fortunately
limited I'll be back I would like to ask
you a personal question if I may you are
at the helm of a country where the
Catholic Church plays a significant role
in society ninety percent of your
compatriots are Catholics but you are
regarded as a person rather critical
towards religion in general how does
that fit really personal I'm agnostic
and I clearly declared declarative
before elections and many people are
shocked somehow that Catholic country
decided to
someone who is not Catholic but I think
it's a nice face of Croatia because
definitely collisions are not some kind
of fanatics and this civil society and
civil approach to the state was overhang
in during this elections and I have very
fair very good relation with Catholic
Church as well like with the other parts
of our society slovenia and soon croatia
two former yugoslav republics are
members of the new relations between the
other former yugoslav states often tends
sometimes even hostile I wonder what
croatia can do to improve the situation
on the balkans so we have to start from
ourselves during my campaign I mentioned
two important goals one was EU and
second it is the other side of the same
coin as better relations with neighbors
and really our relations with neighbors
are much better than five or ten years
ago we have many agreements we have many
cooperation and so but of course there
are some open issues and the
government's should really intensify
efforts to resolve them just in few days
president Nicolas will be to celebrate
with us there are serving present yes
sir be present Nicosia will be also
presidency of boss Ian hetsig all in all
three members there will be presence of
all neighboring countries and I think
that's kind of good spirit in spite of
some differences we have and our
position is to support our neighbors on
their European path supporting them
Serbia Bosnia Kosovo to name just a few
means that does that mean that you will
help them to become members of the
European Union we are going to support
political and I also already said even
technically they need some support we
had support from the other country
countries from European Union during our
negotiation process and we are willing
to offer it to the other countries as
well mr. president Croatia will soon
a member of the European Union but is
there really much enthusiasm in Croatia
among creations towards the you towards
Brussels so I think it's really stick
and our referendum and all pool shows
that about two-thirds of our citizens
are supporting you and that's I think
you know we are realistic we know that
our membership will not resolve our
problems it's good opportunity for us
and I hope we are going to take
advantage of it but the turnout at the
elections for the European Parliament
here was only twenty one percent yeah
it's not the worst in the Europe but
it's porn yes I agree I agree it's poor
there are different reasons economical
situation there is elections after more
important political parties and there
was I think an appropriate approach from
some media and political parties to
present those elections as fight for
good salaries in european parliament and
of course let's run the you you are
joining right now is in a deep crisis
what about the euro does your can't
country also plan to adopt the euro as a
compass compass that we have to meet the
requirements for it and I think that
it's not possible very soon three to
five years that's three to five years
but practically we have you review ask
anyone was the price of anything your
flat or house or whatever you will have
a senior's not in our nation currency
and more than eighty percent of our
savings in banks are in euros nothing
national carrots in Brussels you often
hear rather grim assessments of the
economic situation of Croatia and many
wonder if your country is going to
become the next use headache I'm sure
that you are not going to be next
headache you get a new opportunity for
you investors from Europe and from third
countries so in spite difficulties we
have I
harwich that Croatia will be successful
story in the future but Croatia is in a
deep and long lasting recession yes for
five years for five years now
independent rankings right Croatia less
competitive than Greece competitors is
one thing and of course a result are the
other we didn't start with foreign
investments properly and now we have new
opportunity to possibilities as a new
member of V you there is new legislation
prepared by the government at the
Parliament that will motivate investors
and I have courage that it will happen
what are concrete plans to get the
economy going again the economy must be
supported by investors that means that
we need new investors nebo working
places because unemployment it's very
high is the biggest social and political
and economical problem there are many
very concrete projects offered by the
government infrastructure projects
energetic project and now there are
negotiations with not only did European
but also with some investors from third
countries of China from united states
and the others when romania and bulgaria
joined the you in 2007 the pace of
reform in both countries quickly came to
a halt can you read through a Brussels
your partner's there that this will not
repeat itself in crashes case I think I
think they understand that changed we
had I irreversible especially fighting
corruption it's very important this
chapter twenty third was crucial because
we were considered this corrupted
country yes we had and we still have
problems with corruption like the other
countries but the way of thinking
towards corruption is changed and there
is no president or prime minister or
minister or whomever who can turn the
wheel back so i have to stress also that
we consider all important cases of
corruption we have many of them now
before courts many of them are connected
to European countries so let's do it
together do you feel really welcoming
the European Union and this union which
is going I repeated through a deep deep
crisis yes we feel really welcome but I
always asked myself is the root of the
crisis in EU itself or in economies of
particular countries and I'm convinced
that the crisis is starting from
particular economies and I always ask
myself what will happened with Greece
without you so probably together in EU
be a more capable to confront the crisis
then along it will you super which
president of Croatia thank you very much
for joining us on deutsche welle thank
you very much
you